if you're looking for ways to create
massive confidence and want to learn
from the master himself mr. Tony Robbins
then this video is for you was I believe
nation it seven my one word is believe
and I believe in you I want to see that
amazing thing that you have inside you
be unleashed unto the world and I
started the mentor me seriously try to
learn from people who've done more than
us so we can learn from them aspire to
be similar to them get some of their
beliefs their value system their mindset
their work routine into ourselves that
help us be the best version of ourselves
so today we're gonna learn from Tony
Robbins on how to create massive
confidence mentor me Tony
[Music]
all of us have kind of an identity for
ourselves a way of defining ourselves
and human beings don't usually stray
from that so if you consider yourself to
be a conservative person or a shy person
I know the way you move to some extent I
know the facial expressions the gestures
I use your body and it's all consistent
with the fact that human beings our
strongest Drive is the need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
if your self definition is I'm a
situation where I'm kind of what was the
word he used a shy shy then you're gonna
find a way to get to a place where you
kind of cower back right that's this
thing you can do to change your
experience would be to create a new
little thing a simple thing like erase
the meaning I'm shy go erase that's a BS
story the BS meaning belief system
that's just a story and if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe it you
act like it when you cook calling
yourself shy you believe you have always
been shot up until this moment do
something that's completely outside what
you would normally do something become
somebody else decide who's the most
playful passionate outrageous fun person
you know and behave like them for two or
three days just push yourself to behave
like that here's what's happened it'll
be shocking you'll be weird it'll be
different you'll feel uncomfortable but
after a while you'll get reinforced it's
like if you get a nice haircut you make
a change in way you look people
compliment you you'll get some
compliments and those compliments will
make you want to use those other parts
yourself we all want to be able to
change the way we feel that's what I
spend my life showing people how to deal
on what most people know is the emotion
is created by motion the way you move
determines the way you feel you have 80
different muscles in your face 80 for
most people this is the largest area of
unemployment in the country they use
their mate the face the same way they
feel the same emotions over and over and
over again so what I'm saying is I have
this deal with myself called priming
every day I say look you've got to have
10 minutes for yourself you know 10
minutes to yourself you don't have a
life and I'm not gonna hope I feel good
I don't got back six countries in twelve
days I was in India two days ago Wow
I woke up here wanting like feeling like
somebody ran me over they do this
process it's ten minutes that put some
music on I do this massive change in my
breathing so it radically changes the
way I feel and then I do this three step
process first I do three minutes of grad
- I think of three things I'm really
grateful for and I associate I don't
think of it over there I feel it and the
reason is when you're grateful you can't
be worried
it can't be fearful when you're grateful
you can't be angry and anger and fear
what screw people up most in their
relationships and their life in their
business so I wire myself I'm saying to
you that most people want to be happy
but their habit is to be worried or
pissed off or frustrated or stress and
so they're they've got a high way to
stress and they got a dirt road to
happiness
so I wire myself I've got a highway to
gratitude which changes all your
emotions and then I do three-minute
process of kind of a prayer for my
family and friends and then I do a
three-minute process of the top three
things I want to accomplish I see it as
done and I feel I'm done in 10 minutes
so sunlamp leggo 20 but my deal is 10 so
there's no excuse not to do it most
people have a belief about what their
real potential isn't matter what you
tell them and that affects how much
action they take and of course that
affects the result and then ironically
that result reinforces their belief and
then that belief affects it so I'll give
an example let's say a person has
unlimited potential we all agree but
they take little action little results
why because they have to start with a
problem with their belief they don't
believe it's really gonna happen for me
maybe for Frank Kern's cuz it got the
cool hair and stuff or maybe it's for
you because you're so driven but it's
not me maybe Tony Robbins because she's
a freak up these big teeth whatever
their thought process is right they got
this thing right but what happens is if
you believe that there's very little
potential how much action you gonna take
and when you take a little potential
with a little action what kind of
results you get lousy little results we
need a little results what does that do
to your belief you go see I told you
this was a waste of time soldier this
wouldn't work and then what happens you
tap even less potential you take even
less actually even the worst results and
your belief gets even weaker and this
sucker feeds on itself until you are in
a downward spiral poisonous it's
poisonous and it's self-fulfilling
now what if something could happen that
could come along and fill you with a
sense of absolute certainty not like I
believe but mean well you know and you
guys this case mine as well we knew
because we had to because we burned the
boats there was no other option we had
the way we that we were gonna live that
way we all did it in different ways and
for different reasons but in that sense
that was it if you get yourself in a
state of certainty that this is gonna
work I'm gonna find the way and if this
is work I will make the way then you tap
a lot more potential than when you're
certain your potential you take massive
action when you take massive action you
really believe in something you get
great results when you get great results
your brain goes see I told you I was a
stud I told you this thing would worked
out now you even stronger you have more
potential take greater action be results
that's how you went from 300 bucks in a
week to twenty five hundred and five
days to a hundred thousand in a month to
a million bucks in a day same thing with
you and we get momentum so why the rich
get richer the poor get poorer now some
people go out they go well I'm gonna
take a bunch of action all right I'm
gonna open this product we're gonna try
it they'll say to you I even did it but
it's like the sales when it goes and
knocks on the door he knocks on a
hundred doors and says verbally his face
says it because he doesn't believe it's
gonna work
so his voice his body the execution is
so weak maybe if he talks to hundred
people so he's gonna buy on a pity I'm
gonna win his kids to starve right but
he's not gonna get the result so the
core difference in people is how do you
produce certainty when the world isn't
giving it to you you go out and try and
you try in your case your hundred
thousand a debt nothing's working how do
you keep yourself going the way you did
it the way I did it the way you're doing
it we may not done it consciously is we
didn't change our potential that was
there and it wasn't even taking more
action taking more action with beliefs
not gonna works not gonna change
anything we got results in our head that
made us feel certain as if it had
already happened I want to show you what
you can do with just focus try this for
a moment I'm gonna give you a test sit
up in your chair with some energy make
sure buddy next using a strong state if
otherwise adjust their state come on
change your physiology what are they
gonna do see if they're ticklish that
might help now do this I want to look
around this room right now and find
everything in this room that you can
find it is brown as fast you can look
for Brown look for Brown look for Brown
look for Brown look around you look for
Brown look for Brown look for Brown okay
close your eyes I'm gonna give you tests
with your eyes closed now shout out loud
everything you saw that was red
if you see a lot more brown right now
than red say yes open your eyes look for
red now I want you to really look for
red look for red look for red look for
red anything exciting it's red look for
red all around you look for red raise
your hand if you feeling more red this
time and say aye
why did you find more red this time cuz
seek and you shall that's right whenever
you focus on you're gonna find it in
fact let me tell you something you'll
even find it when it's not there how
many saw burgundy called it red just so
you can have more things you count it
raise your hand say I come on see
whatever you're looking for you're gonna
find so if you want to change your life
my friends you've got to change your
physiology and you got to change your
focus by the way how fast can you change
that stuff how fast my friends how fast
how fast come on and a heart beat once
you reach Ange your conditioning it's
all you got to do ain't gonna fast you
do it a question or two try this right
now answer this question in your mind
and be honest what in your life today if
you want it to be could you feel proud
about right now if you wanted to feel
proud if you didn't elect I shouldn't be
proud if you want to feel proud what
could you be proud of in your life today
your children your health your body is
there a problem you faced instead of
running from it you finally stepped up
and handled it could you feel proud of
in your life too that if you wanted to
feel proud how many could bigger
something and when you think about this
thing you're proud of what about that
makes you feel proud what do you focus
on that makes you feel proud how do you
breathe when you really start to feel
proud that's what kind of look on your
faces starts to happen when you let
yourself feel proud yeah how's that feel
think of another area life think of any
of your life that you're grateful for or
you are not grateful if you wanted to be
grateful what's an area you could feel
grateful for what could you feel
grateful for if you really wanted to
feel grateful
how many can think of something you can
feel grateful for these here's your
hands and what about that are you
grateful for what do you focus on that
makes you feel grateful how does it feel
when you're really truly feeling filled
with gratitude here's one if you wanted
to be excited about your life right now
and you were willing to be excited you
wrote a book everybody else's trend what
could you feel excited about in your
life if you wanted to feel excited what
could you get excited about if you
really focused on it and you really took
it in and you weren't at a negative
place what could you get excited about
if you wanted to be excited in your life
what could you get excited about how
many of you can think of something you
feel excited about right now raise your
hand let me see use your hand say aye
when you're really excited about it what
about that excites you or when you're
really excited how do you feel how do
you speak what's your life like by the
way when you're excited does it tend to
touch other people yes or no absolutely
by the way do people have a tendency but
who feels different right now they're
just even a couple moments ago raise
your hand say aye
why because focus is controlled by
questions if you ask a different
question continuously that once
continuously you will get a different
answer if you ask a lousy question you
get a lousy answer in a lousy state
somebody said why does this always
happen to me it doesn't always happen to
you but the brains like a computer ask
it a question it'll have to come up with
an answer
cuz you deserve it you idiot someone
will say how come I can never lose
weight you can't lose weight but if you
keep saying how come I can't ever lose
weight that means gotta come in answer
goes you're a pig
lousy questions great what lousy answers
ask a better question get a better
answer now here's what I want you to get
I want you to get that you can change
your stain how fast guys how fast how
fast and if you get the habit of doing
it you have a different life the motion
is created by motion if you want to
change the way you feel if you ever try
to do with your head I'm not being happy
your brain goes BS you're not happy but
if you change the way you move your body
radically enough your voice your face
your movement your biochemistry changes
it's not a pump up it's a true
biochemical change so what I like you to
do in your chair create more energy than
you had when you're standing that means
you got to wake up your room whatever
you gotta do use your voice use your
body go wake him up wake him up
come on now
[Music]
that's it now don't let it go sit up in
your chair show the people beside you
what a peak state looks like by your
example just show them if you find your
passion you're gonna have this
tremendous energy it's a sustainable
energy but momentum requires you always
do the next thing that keep the momentum
going and the reason you get yourself in
a passionate place is so that you change
your life and the only thing that
changes your life is making a decision
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions you
don't make decisions when you're like
huh I don't know what do you think
all right let's decide if you make a
decision in a state without momentum if
you make a decision from a place where
there's no passion you are not gonna get
momentum it'll kill momentum
it's decide commit and resolve some of
you in the past you've gotten momentum
you've gotten passionate you've even
made a decision but a decision is the
first step
decision is like a war I got to do this
or that all right I'm gonna make myself
through this but commitment is when you
nail after you've decided you commit to
do this for the long term whether it's
hard or easy doesn't matter you're doing
this it takes it from this moment and it
carries it in the future even when
things are difficult and the third state
is resolved resolved
means it's done it's like it doesn't
even if you took action it's done inside
you so it's done out there there's no
question whatsoever then once you decide
the only way that commitment and the
energy and the momentum continues is if
you take immediate massive what my
friends massive life write down in your
notes massive action is the cure-all
massive action is the cure-all if you're
having a difficult time with something
your relationship isn't where you
to be your finances are not where you
want to be your body's not where you
want to be your business is not where
you want to be you need to take massive
action and if that doesn't work try
something else so that's just work try
something else keep going with massive
action and you will find the way because
it will give you momentum so thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what did you
think of this video what clip resonated
the most with you what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or your business leave some love down in
the comments below I'm looking forward
to hearing from you I also want to give
a quick shout out to the S attina artist
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and doing the
review on your YouTube channel I really
really really appreciate it and I'm so
glad you enjoyed the book I just
finished your one word by Evan
Carmichael Evans latest book and I have
a lot to say about it so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
so it would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]